he he was he was a brilliant uh chess  player throughout his career he's one of  the young and the last soviet world  champion yeah um and he was very very  talented at a young age and he had this  uh maybe we have a move listen oh yeah  so we do wow we do have  g3s g3 really been played yeah okay  we're about to see a result okay i think  there's this yeah definitely this must  be going to a draw right no no no  jan has chosen to fall on his sword this  is just a blunder  um wow he's just i think he just knows  it's one last roll of the dice um a draw  today and the match is almost over  anyway and uh  right now it's the variation we showed  black can just take the white knight the  black queen is going to come in it's  going to be a deadly attack and magnus  is going to win  wow this is unbelievable is about to win  the game and therefore yeah the 2021  world championship match  wow